[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a fantasy drama film
called marriage simulator
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
in the opening scene we are introduced
to a beautiful japanese girl named
chiharu takajo she is stranded at a bus
stop because of the pouring rain a young
man yuichi tokunagi gets off a bus and
joins her he tries to start a
conversation with chiharu but she is
dismissive of his efforts yuichi takes
the hint and quits talking they wait for
the rain to stop in complete silence but
after waiting for several minutes both
of them get bored yuichi notices a film
poster behind them and comments that he
has always wanted to watch it chiharu
also claims that she hasn't watched a
movie in a long time the pair goes
silent again but yuichi takes a chance
and asks chiharu to go out on a movie
date with him she is left stunned and
quite nervous about going out with a
stranger but yuichi doesn't give her a
chance to answer and runs to buy two
tickets chiharu smiles at him and the
two start to date from that day onwards
they are so madly in love with each
other that after dating for only a few
months they decide to get married a
wedding planner gives them a tour of a
chapel and briefs them about the
anniversary gift services they provide
the couple buys a package where their
anniversary gifts until the 10th year of
their marriage will be sent by the
company the gift for the 10th
anniversary is a customized video that
they will have to shoot for their future
selves chiharu excitedly compares the
videos to a time capsule however yuichi
is not so confident about it yet he
agrees to participate for his fiancee in
the following scene they shoot the
videos professionally yuichi awkwardly
asks the camera about their 10th
anniversary while chiharu leaves a
delightful message for a 35 year old
yuichi that evening they go to the
wedding planner to finalize their venue
as they talk chiharu notices an
advertisement for a package that the
company provides it describes a special
program that helps a couple to take a
look at their future life with each
other the planner says that the program
is called the marriage simulator and
most couples use it to find out if they
are really compatible he asks them if
they want to apply but the pair is
skeptical when shiharu returns home that
day she and her roommate talk about her
upcoming marriage according to her
roommate the couple is making the
decision hastily chiharu claims that
they are happy in their relationship and
know that they are making a good
decision besides people who think too
much about it never get married these
days the roommate jokingly gives the
example of a dress that chiharu
impulsively bought some months ago and
war only once she suggests chiharu think
about the marriage again because they
have been dating for only a few months
when she expresses her relief about not
marrying her former boyfriend shiharu
does start to question her decision to
be absolutely sure about marrying him
she decides to apply to the marriage
simulator program and convinces yuichi
as well in the following scene they are
at the company's headquarters discussing
the program the officials explain that
the scientists can predict how the
couple's marriage life will be by
examining their dna their medical data
their personal background and their
character profiles this way their future
married life is simulated in the form of
a dream and shown to the couple
following that they acquire chiharu and
yuichi's blood samples and lots of
medical data along with their background
history then the two are seated in
special chairs and a device is attached
to their heads the doctor warns them
that the future they see through the
device is not absolute and might change
according to their emotional reactions
finally the device starts and they are
made to fall asleep at first the couple
dreams about their wedding day they
stand in front of the guests who cheer
for them happily stepping into the next
part of their lives the first morning
after the wedding they wake up and are
just as happy chiharu has made breakfast
for yuichi that the two enjoy together
that is until they realize that they
prefer different side dishes with their
breakfast it is only a small compromise
that the two have to make but it doesn't
end there chiharu discovers that yuichi
always leaves the toilet seat up which
causes a minor argument again one of
them has to compromise when they go to
sleep at night chiharu has the habit of
leaving the lights on but yuichi cannot
fall asleep with them on somehow they
haven't figured this out yet in the same
way as time passes the couple eventually
realizes that their lifestyles are very
different from each other one day
chiharu has enough of her husband not
listening to her so she tells him that
she feels underappreciated yuichi on the
other hand puts the blame on her for
never dressing up putting on makeup and
looking pretty ooh
that was a stupid stupid thing to say
yuichi following that the couple is
woken up for a break yuichi says that he
knows kung fu they're clearly not happy
after watching what their future will be
like they try to be optimistic and
assume that they will eventually get
used to living with each other yuichi
says that no matter what happens he will
not leave her side while going down the
elevator they come across another couple
who has also just seen their future the
girl is crying because the man is about
to cheat on her he tries to explain that
he would never do something like that
but the marriage simulator has already
predicted the future sometime later they
continue the simulation and dream of
chiharu being pregnant they discuss the
possible names for their child and
decide to name it haruki if it is a boy
and yuka if it is a girl in a few months
chiharu gives birth to a beautiful boy
her mother-in-law calls him yutaro
chiharu looks at yuichi uncomfortably
asking him why the mother is calling
their son a different name the woman
laughs and claims that according to
their family's tradition the first kid
should be something with the letter y
yuichi doesn't want to go against his
mother so he just accepts the name while
chiharu is furious at him for not
mentioning this before on their fifth
anniversary chiharu prepares him a
dinner at home and waits for him for
hours yuichi comes home at midnight and
says that he has already eaten at a
business dinner shiharu is clearly hurt
and upset but yuichi is dismissive of
her effort to make him happy she
suggests they go out for dinner the next
day but yuichi has to attend a golf
match chiharu remembers the day they had
met for the first time and reminisces
about how good life was then chiharu
finally tells him that she is hurt to
which he replies that he works hard to
provide for the family so she should be
happy instead he harshly asks her to
stop bitching so much and be satisfied
with what she has for once in her life
in the following scene the couple is
talking about yutaro's school fees
chiharu wants to start working to be
able to provide their kid with better
things but yuichi insists he already
earns enough for the family chiharu
accuses him of trying to keep her in the
house because he doesn't want her to
grow professionally the two get into yet
another argument and start yelling at
each other they both argue that they
have sacrificed a lot for the family but
are oblivious of what the other person
has done as their screams start getting
louder poor utaro comes to their room
crying because he is scared chiharu
quickly gets up and calms him down as
she is hugging the kid yuichi approaches
her and says that they should separate
for good chiharu just hugs her son
tighter and cries in the next scene they
finally sign the divorce paper moments
later the pair wakes up in the chair the
officials ask them about their
experience but they stay frozen in their
seats they must be shocked by how
predictably their marriage turned out
after composing themselves they get up
and confront each other chiharu is
beyond hurt by what she just witnessed
she slaps yuichi calling him a liar for
promising that he will always stick by
her side yuichi has nothing else to say
he simply claims that it is better they
know this before their wedding because
now they can take a step back and
prevent themselves from wasting time on
each other plus you don't have to pay
for the wedding yuichi you cheap bastard
with that kind of future they do not
want to marry anymore yuichi asks the
wedding planner to cancel the ceremony
the officials are shocked but they
respect the pair's decision shiharu
returns home but she feels like she is
missing a part of herself after breaking
up with yuichi her roommate tries to
console her and advises her to never
marry because all men change after
marriage but the advice does little to
nothing to help her mood for the next
few days she keeps herself busy with
work if she is free she either goes
swimming or hangs out with her friend to
keep the thought of yuichi out of her
mind one day she returns home to see
that she has received a package from the
wedding planner that contained the video
yuichi was supposed to give her on their
10th wedding anniversary as she
contemplates playing it she gets a call
from yuichi it turns out the company
accidentally sent them the opposite
tapes so he asks her to throw them away
chiharu says that she will but after the
call she can't help but play it hoping
to see him one last time in the video
yuichi greets her and apologizes for all
the mistakes he has made throughout the
years he admits he can be
non-communicative sometimes and claims
that even though he doesn't say it he
loves her a lot to chiharu's surprise he
also confesses that the time they met at
the bus stop was not the first time he
saw her yep you guessed it stalker in
fact he had seen her at the train
station one day and instantly knew that
she was the one following that he always
looked forward to seeing her around the
neighborhood he wanted to approach her
but never had the guts until he saw her
at the bus stop that day he had even
left his umbrella on the bus so he could
spend some time with her yuichi ends the
video by telling her that they should go
to a movie theater and see if they are
showing a romantic film if they are by
chance showing one that will mean that
they were always meant to be given how
popular rom-coms are yuichi made a smart
bet here by the end of the video chiharu
is left sobbing she has a hundred things
going on in her mind without thinking
much she runs to the movie theater that
they went to on their first date to her
disappointment it is showing a horror
movie instead of a romantic one she is
about to return when suddenly yuichi
also arrives and asks her to come to the
movies with him the pair smiles at each
other and reunites
then we find out that they are still
watching the simulation them canceling
the wedding was also part of it the
couple opens their eyes still trying to
comprehend the roller coaster of
emotions they have felt in the past two
hours they get up from their seats and
do not say a word to each other the
planner congratulates them and asks them
about the experience but still the pair
doesn't speak in the following scene we
see them walking through a park they
have not talked to each other since
watching the simulation after walking
for a long time they hold hands and
smile at each other subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching